these two tangents they're not just
random they both share a particular
property in common right they're not
just random tangents where do they both
go
think about how you drew them in the
first place don't both of these tangents
go through here this is the one thing
that they have in common but literally
the one thing okay now if you have a
point that's on a line and you know the
equations of these two lines then this
point ought to satisfy these equations
do you agree with that so we can write
some relationships how this do this with
me right next to where you've got your
equations of the tangents I can
substitute X naught Y naught into both
those equations and they should both be
true because my external point is on
those tangents okay
so what would that look like hmm I'm
gonna get X naught instead of X and then
I'm gonna keep on writing until I find a
new thing to substitute uh-huh here we
go instead of Y I'm gonna write Y naught
because that's the particular set of
coordinates I'm interested in right so
what are we saying this is the equation
of the tangent and this is a statement
that's true because X naught Y naught is
on that tangent okay
I might say since X naught y naught is
on the tangent that's where I get this
equation from and likewise I can repeat
this exercise for the second tangent
right this is also true
how's your brain doing so far this is it
okay
I haven't done anything dramatic though
it doesn't seem like I've made much
progress at all but watch out because
I'm literally one line away from the
proof but the formula is going to come
on the next line there's no more work to
do but the question is how do I get to
that next line and that's what this clue
is about and what does that look like to
you
this thing over here look so that looks
like table values right now this table
of values it's like two points out in
space okay if you don't know anything
else about them that's that's all they
are however I told you that actually hey
these two points they're actually gonna
line somewhere I'm interested in lines
at the moment right then you could find
the equation of this line there's a lot
of ways you could do it so I want to
give me example of what you could do you
could do to pour formula because there's
two points right there's an even easier
thing you could not even easier there's
an algebraically less demanding thing
that you could do if you know that these
are on a straight line right what's the
gradient of this line can you tell me
the gradient have a look look at the
numbers
think the gradients for right the
gradients for because the rise is for
the run in particular we have is one so
forever one is for okay so if the
gradient is for I only need one other
piece of information to get the whole
equation of the line
I suppose I could put into point
gradient form but come on you can
probably work this out
what's the widest that gonna be just
just how about numbers they're not
complicated it's gonna be minus 1 right
because look the y-intercept occurs when
x equals 0 right and if that is the case
then you're going back you're going down
I should say four more units so that
lands you at negative one is that okay
so look now we have a guess there's my
gradient which you told me after some
cook team and on there's your
y-intercept okay now how would we know
whether we were right what will we do we
test it out and it's not complicated to
test we'd say it well okay let's take on
one three and let's put it into the
equation and see what happens right is
it true that three equals four times one
takeaway one checks out what's good is
it true that seven equals four times to
take away one and you'd say yeah looks
good so this is enough confirmation for
me if there is a straight line that goes
through both of those then I'm content
that y equals four X minus one is that
line okay now I'm gonna do something a
little bit weird okay you guys know in
math sometimes we're very good at using
a piece of knowledge or an idea in one
direction I couldn't think of a
substitute phrase for that but anyway
but we're not very good at using it in
Reverse
okay so I'm with circle properties for
example we're really good at being told
that things are equal and then inferring
things but it's harder to go in the
opposite direction I'm gonna try and get
your brains to do exactly that because
that's the key to what's happening over
here suppose you didn't start with all
that information over there suppose you
just started
with this okay what does this tell you
what does this tell you what can we
infer that's true just from these
statements okay what I see is there's a
rule that's in operation on both of
these lines okay there's a rule that's
operating and you can see what the rule
is because some things stay the same and
other things change okay what things
stay the same from both lines from one
line to the other I should say okay the
negative one is still there both times
and there's also a for this guy right so
therefore I'm sort of saying that
there's a common DNA for both of these
there's an equal sign there's a for
there's something in here and a take
away one and then there's something over
here
do you agree so when I look at these I
see they both conform to a pattern if I
had more of them right I'd say what
hopefully they all conform to this
patent that's where I got them from okay
and then I have a look at what changes
these guys and these guys okay now what
this says to me is well these were
x-values worth day these were x-values
and these were y-values now what I've
done is I've arrived at the same answer
which is a relief right but I've come
from a totally different direction I
didn't come from coordinates and then
make an equation I came for the equation
and I made of generalized version of
that equation from these specialized
versions does that make sense
like these guys are what this looks like
in particular times in particular places
okay now take that idea and bring it to
these two equations you've just written
remember over here we found two things
in common I saw the fours were in common
so I wrote a for you guys saw their
minus one was in common so we wrote
minus one tell me what's in common
between these two lines is quite a few
things - a is in common what else
why not is in common what else X knots
in common so in other words I'm
inferring that from here
both of these are like specialized
version of some general thing that
exists out here what's the pattern well
it's going to have an X naught in it at
the front and then it's going to have
something else in there because that
thing changes I don't know what that is
yet
it's gonna have a 2 a because these all
have 2a in them it's gonna have a Y
naught because these all have Y naught
in them and then you add something okay
now we can look at the something's right
these guys they change but they're both
X values if both X values just like
these were both X values oh great so I'm
gonna put an X in there where are these
guys well they change but they're both Y
values just like the 3 and the 7 were Y
values so I'm gonna put Y there okay now
I'm just gonna rearrange this a teeny
bit and then I'm gonna ask you to tell
me what this means X naught times X is
the same as X X naught right like
multiplication I don't care about the
order yeah just like I don't care about
the order of multiplication I don't care
about the order of addition either yeah